le front national bien décidés à passer
la vitesse supérieure après le retour de
marine le pen dans les médias steeve
briois mobilise ses troupes et affiche
sa confiance
le vice-président du front national le
répète si elle accède au second tour de
cette présidentielle
sa candidate peut l'emporter front
républicain ou pas je crois que le front
républicain va voler en éclats et qu'il
n'aura surtout plus aucune efficacité
nous n'avons vu partout ailleurs les
gens en ont tellement marre des conseils
des uns et des autres qu'au second tour
et vont voter pour leurs convictions et
sont prêts à faire le le das franchir le
pas nécessaire
un message sens et galvaniser le millier
de militants frontistes que compte
l'indre et loire
côté programme marine le pen dévoilera
ses idées à lyon en février
en attendant ses lieutenants pour
mission de taper sur fion un peu mais
surtout sur macron troisième dans les
sondages c'est la personnalité qui est
le plus mise en scène actuellement la
plus valorisée donc normal qu'on
l'attaquent peu s'en souviennent mais il
était au gouvernement de monsieur
hollande c'est la cas qui vient du monde
de la finance
donc je pense pas que quelqu'un qui va
du monde de la finance qu'à travailler
chez rothschild puisse défendre le
peuple
en indre et loire véronique payant
secrétaire départemental et candidate
aux législatives sera chargé d'animer la
campagne
mauvaise nouvelle pour les militants
marine le pen ne viendra pas à tour
en revanche elle est attendu à
châteauroux ce sera le 11 mars